General tessellation won't help. Adding vertices will just mean more triangles
to join these up. The answer is 4 triangles in fact the rule is a polygon with n
edges will need n minus 2 triangles to represent it. We don't care all that much
in interactive rendering which triangulation is used. Here I've made a fan of
triangles, all radiating from 1 vertex but there are other ways to do it. The
shape of the triangles is important in other fields such as stress analysis
program that use meshes but isn't so important in interactive rendering. If
you're a puzzle buff here's a bonus question for absolutely no credit and little
use in computer graphics itself rather just for the sake of it. How many
different unique triangulations of this hexagon are there? Once you solve that,
is there a general rule for polygons? Feel free to discuss this on the forums.